[Musique]
l'importance du procès de klaus barbie
s'était pas tant la condamnation chacun
savait qu'un contenu qu il fait que les
psychiatres avaient déclaré que parmi
tes normale entre guillemets lac
réclusion criminelle à perpétuité était
quasiment acquise le procès s'était
véritablement d'offrir une unité de
temps et de lieu pour permettre à la
parole des victimes de prendre toute sa
place
les victimes n'avait jusqu'à lors
quasiment jamais parlé ou n'avait parlé
que par bribes
les victimes étaient gênés soit par
pudeur soit par la crainte de se faire
plaindre
les victimes ne parlait que très peu
même en direction de leurs familles et
c'est ainsi que le procès barbie a été
une sorte de déclencheur pour permettre
à ces victimes de se dire si je ne parle
pas l'occasion de ce procès je ne
parlerai jamais et le procès barbie est
entré dans l'histoire par commander
cette victoire sur l'indicible qu'il est
parvenu à réaliser
c'est ça la leçon du procès barbie et
robert badinter le garde des sceaux de
l'époque l'avait bien perçue par avance
qui avait fait voter en 1985 une loi
spéciale permettant l'enregistrement
audiovisuel de la totalité des débats du
procès barbie et au delà des procès
ayant une dimension historique
c'est dans l'ancienne prison militaire
de montluc à lyon prison militaire
depuis 1921 et kiala au début des années
1940 3 fin janvier 1943 a été
réquisitionné par klaus barbie pour en
faire la prison de la gestapo lyonnaise
klaus barbie était arrivé au moment du
franchissement de la ligne de
démarcation et de l'occupation de lyon
fin 1942 et après avoir installé les
bureaux de ces gestapo à l'hôtel du
château perrache plus à l'école de santé
militaire et bien barbie a eu évidemment
pour souci de se constituer sa propre
prison il a donc réquisitionné à partir
de fin janvier 1943 cette prison de
montluc en a expulsé ses occupants des
détenus qui étaient incarcérés pour
opposition régime de vichy et c'est
ainsi que 2 février 1943 au dernier jour
d'août 1944
barbie a réuni ici des juifs des
résistants des rafles et ce sont au
total plus de dix mille détenus détenu
par la gestapo lyonnaise qui ont
transité par cette prison montluc
montluc était un lieu de regroupement
des différentes personnes arrêtées
montluc n'était qu'un lieu de transit
bien que certains détenus y soit demeuré
durant plusieurs mois
c'est à dire que régulièrement il y
avait des appels avec ou sans bagage
sans bagage c'était
la conduite d'un certain nombre de
détenus aux portes de lyon pour des
exécutions sommaires et avec bagages
c'était le transport de détenus dans des
convois qui partait de perrache
les résistants partait en direction de
compiègne camp de regroupement des
résistants pour ensuite les camps de
concentration de mathausen duquesne val
d'arrats haut et caetera et les juifs
étaient regroupés adro si doux se
formait les sinistres convoi de wagons à
bestiaux essentiellement à destination
du camp d'auschwitz-birkenau donc
montluc était véritablement la plaque
tournante de la répression nazie
c'est là que l'on regroupe les gens pour
ensuite les diriger soit vers la
solution finale soit soir vers les camps
d'extermination des résistants
[Musique]
alors un premier temps les cellules ont
été occupés bien qu'il s'agisse de
minuscules cellules de moins d'un mètre
carré on y loge est entre 6 et 8
personnes et lorsque la surpopulation a
été tel que l'on pouvait plus contente
et d'incarcérer des gens dans les
cellules eh bien on a utilisé tous les
locaux annexes que ce soit les ateliers
que ce soit les buanderies c'est ainsi
que l'incarcération à montluc c'était
les cellules les locaux annexes est plus
une baraque une baraque qui se trouvait
au centre de la cour une vieille baraque
qui accueillait jusqu'à 300 personnes
il y avait des résistants mais il y
avait aussi des juifs et cette présence
importante de juifs à l'intérieur de
cette baraka fait dénommé ce bâtiment
cette baraque baraque au juge ce nom est
resté c'est un nom qui a été notamment
mis en valeur par andré frossard qui
était à la fois juif et résistant ce
grand chroniqueur ce grand écrivain qui
a à la fin de la guerre écrit un ouvrage
important décrivant la vie dans ce qu'il
appelait bien la baraque aux juifs
[Musique]
ab à barbie a été nommé le boucher de
lyon parce que il était le responsable
de la gestapo lyonnaise de la répression
nazie boucher de lyon et bien ça veut
dire qu'il n'a jamais fait de sentiment
est que pour lui son serment de s est
lui imposait d'être intraitable avec les
résistants de les mettre hors d'état de
nuire et bien évidemment d'assurer la
rafle la plus efficace possible des
juifs que ce soit des vieillards que ce
soit des enfants d'où son surnom de
boucher de lyon
[Musique]
je pense que barbie que klaus barbie est
l'archétype de ce que peuvent fabriquer
le fanatisme klaus barbie était un
garçon bien sous tous rapports à 13 14
15 ans il me dit tu es dans des
associations humanitaires il s'occupe
aide de secourir des prisonniers de les
visiter etc etc
jusqu'au jour où en 1933 alors qu'il est
encore au lycée et qu'il veut faire des
études de théologie c'est peu dire il va
perdre successivement la même année son
père est son unique frère et le voici
seul avec sa mère et 1933 cette année
terrible où hitler prend tous les
pouvoirs et barbie va à ce moment là
être captées par les jeunesses
hitlériennes va être captée par cette
organisation nazie où il va trouver
beaucoup de confraternité où il va
trouver un esprit communautaire où il va
trouver une chaleur humaine
et là évidemment c'est le piège parce
que ont valu un style est bien
évidemment non seulement le le culte du
führer mais également le culte de ses
idées et l'enseignement de mein kampf
fait partie bien sûr du lavage de
cerveau que subissent les membres des
jeunesses hitlériennes et très
rapidement on va repérer klaus barbie
comme un garçon extrêmement intelligent
extrêmement convaincu de de cette
philosophie folles et c'est dans ces
conditions que l'on va bien sûr le
sélectionner pour suivre l'école de
formation des ss et qui va devenir un
jeune lieutenant ss extrêmement
extrêmement efficace extrêmement
apprécié de ses supérieurs on a retrouvé
des fiches de notation de klaus barbie
dans sa jeunesse
ss ce sont des fiches particulièrement
élogieuse
[Musique]
klaus barbie a quitté lyon dans les
heures qui ont précédé la libération de
lyon klaus barbie qui était quelqu'un de
très intelligent a bien compris qu'à
mesure que les libérateurs de la
provence à la suite du débarquement du
15 août 1944 remontait la vallée du
rhône que lyon elle était libérée il
fallait absolument qu'il sait qu'il
quitte les lieux
et c'est ainsi que de lui même il a
quitté les lieux et qu'au moment de la
libération et bien officiellement il a
était introuvable
jeudi officiellement parce que très vite
après la libération du territoire
français on l'a retrouvé en allemagne
n'ont pas les français mais des
américains et les américains ont bien
compris que barbie laure était très
utile nous étions aux portes de la
guerre froide et les américains avaient
besoin d'anciens cadres de la gestapo
qui connaissait particulièrement les
réseaux communistes en europe pour
justement permettre aux américains de
débusquer ces réseaux communiste et
c'est ainsi que barbie va devenir un
agent de renseignement tout à fait
officielle des services de renseignement
américains agents officiellement
immatriculé agents rémunérés et c'est
ainsi que barbie pendant plusieurs
années va bénéficier de la protection
des autorités américaines qui vont même
favorisé lorsqu'ils en auront plus
besoin son exfiltration d'europe en
direction de l'amérique du sud
et c'est ainsi que barbie va se
retrouver un beau jour en bolivie sous
la fausse identité de klaus altmann sous
laquelle il va pouvoir obtenir la
nationalité bolivienne et que barbie va
être là bas est bien dans la certitude
qu'il est définitivement à l'abri de
toute espèce de poursuite avec les
autorités françaises par les autorités
françaises pour une bonne raison c'est
qu'ils collaborent activement au régime
la bolivie est alors dirigé par un
régime dictatorial deux colonels de
généraux et caetera et barbie est devenu
le conseiller technique du ministre de
l'intérieur
il a même acquis c'est très symbolique
le titre de colonel honoraire de larmes
bolivienne et c'est ainsi que lorsque la
france voudra récupérer klaus barbie
pour le juger parce qu'il avait été
jugée à deux reprises en 1952 et 1954
pour un certain nombre d'exactions ils
avaient été condamnés à mort il avait
été condamné à mort par contumace
on n'avait pas pu ramener cette secte
deux condamnations à mort à exécution ce
qui fait que barbie bien sûr va être à
l'abri de toute poursuite et qu'en 1969
lorsque le président de la république
française georges pompidou demande la
bolivie l'extradition de barbieux oppose
bien évidemment une fin de non recevoir
alors il y aura l'entrée en scène de
deux grands chasseurs de nazis français
que chacun connaît serge et béate
klarsfeld qui vont tenter d'organiser un
soulèvement de barbie non pas pour
l'exécuter mais pour le remettre à la
justice française ils vont s'entourer de
la collaboration d'un intellectuel
français qui étaient partis sur place
qui s'appelait régis debray partis sur
place pour soutenir che guevara qui
avaient été emprisonnés qui avait été
libéré et ils vont tenter d'organiser
l'enlèvement de barbie avec l'aide la
collaboration d'un opposant au régime
qui s'appelle du ca vaut sanchez salazar
et ce gustavo sanchez salazar va les
aider à enlever barbie malheureusement
ces tentatives d'enlèvement va échouer
ce qui fait que pendant nombreuses
années eh bien on a quasiment dû faire
le deuil d'un retour de barbie sur le
territoire français cela était très
ennuyeux cela était très gênant parce
que la prescription de la peine en
france était de 20 ans c'est à dire que
la dernière condamnation remonte en 1954
passé 1974 barbie ne pouvait plus être
poursuivi non seulement poursuivie mais
plus précisément ne pouvait plus boire
ramené à exécution la peine les peines
qui avaient été prononcées contre lui
par bonheur entre temps la loi française
avait
claret imprescriptible le crime contre
l'humanité il ne restait donc plus à la
justice française qu'à voir si parmi les
crimes reprochés à barbie qui n'avait
pas bien sûr été jugé en 52 et en 54 car
on ne peut pas juger bien sûr quelqu'un
deux fois pour la même chose
il n'y avait pas d'effet qui pouvant
recevoir la qualification de crime
contre l'humanité ces nouveaux crimes
qui avaient été définis dans le cadre de
la création du tribunal militaire
international de nuremberg c'est les
célèbres accords de londres de 1945 il
n'y avait pas précisément des faits
constitutifs de crimes contre l'humanité
non jugé en 1952 1954 et qui devenu
imprescriptible permettrait l'engagement
de nouvelles poursuites
et c'est ainsi que très rapidement on a
découvert des faits qui n'avaient pas
été jugé qu' à l'évidence constituer des
crimes contre l'humanité et qui ont
permis l'ouverture d'une nouvelle
procédure
c'est dans ces conditions que le juge
d'instruction de lyon a lancé un mandat
d'arrêt international et ce mandat
d'arrêt a pu recevoir exécution début
parce qu'il ya eu un changement de
régime en bolivie que les colonels ont
été renversés qu'un régime démocratique
s'est installée et qu'au sein du
gouvernement bolivien qui attend trouver
comme vice ministre de l'intérieur
monsieur gustavo sanchez salazar celui
là même qui avait participé aux côtés
des klarsfeld à la tentative
d'enlèvement de barbie et gustavo
sanchez salazar a immédiatement indiqué
aux autorités françaises qu'il était
prête à remettre klaus barbie
par bonheur régis debray à ce moment là
c'est vraiment les grands rendez vous de
l'histoire était conseiller du président
de la république française françois
mitterrand
ce qui fait qu'au plus haut niveau de
l'état eh bien on décida qu'il fallait
et que l'on allait récupérer klaus
barbie
alors il n'y a pas eu d'enlèvement de
klaus barbie il ya eu simplement le
constat par le nouveau gouvernement
audi vient qu'il avait acquis la
nationalité bolivienne d'une manière
totalement illégale puisqu'il l'avait
acquise sous la fausse identité de klaus
altmann lorsqu'on acquiert une
nationalité et que l'on use un nom
d'emprunt
on ne peut pas opposer une acquisition
légal de cette nouvelle nationalité donc
barbie a été renvoyé de bolivie mais
dans un avion bolivien cet avion
bolivien a atterri en guyane territoire
français et c'est là qu'on lui a notifié
le mandat d'arrêt du juge d'instruction
de lyon qu'il a été donc ramené sur le
territoire français nous étions premiers
jours de février 1983 est là et bien il
ya eu un geste symbolique que voulu à
l'époque le garde des sceaux qui était
robert badinter dont le père simon
badinter avait été une des victimes de
klaus barbie et qui demanda qu'à son
arrivée à lyon
symboliquement klaus barbie fut
incarcéré ici à la prison de montluc le
lieu même de ces crimes
et c'était évidemment un geste très fort
hautement symbolique
il fallait que le bourreau revint
répondent devant la justice française de
ces crimes dans le lieu où il avait
commis la répression qu'on lui
reprochait
l'allemagne avait parfaite
adjugé une plainte avait été déposée au
parquet de munich par les époux
klarsfeld et malheureusement cette note
avait été classée sans suite au motif
qu'ils n'étaient pas selon le parquet de
munich
il n'était pas établi qu barbie avait
réellement connaissance de la solution
finale
voilà mais bien évidemment la résolution
des nations unies de 1946 permet à tous
les pays où des exactions avaient été
commises par les nazis d'engager des
poursuites contre les dix nazis dès lors
qu'ils sont vivants et qu'on peut les
retrouver
le premier fait donc que l'on reproche à
barbie est ce que l'on appelle la raf de
la rue sainte catherine
c'est à dire que rue sainte-catherine
n'existait l'union générale des
institutions juives de france a vu une
sorte de centre social où l'on recevait
les familles notamment celles qui
souhaitaient partir pour la suisse et la
barbie organise évidemment une opération
sur ce centre juif et on va prendre en
otages capturés l'ensemble des présents
à la fois le personnel et les gens qui
se présentent plus de 80 personnes qui
vont être immédiatement arrêtés et
conduits vers des camps de concentration
via via drancy et il n'y en aura que
quelques unités d'entre eux qui
reviendront ça c'est le premier fait la
raf de la rue sainte catherine
le second fait que chacun connaisse et
l'arabe des enfants d'izieu le 6 avril
1944 44 enfants du home d'enfants juifs
d'izieu dans le département de l'ain
sont arrêtés jetés dans des camions
conduit ici à la prison montluc pendant
une nuit et dès le lendemain
placés dans des wagons à destination
encore une fois dedans si grand si auch
et là les malheureux enfants de dix yeux
seront gazés exterminés dans les heures
qui
il leur arrivait enfin le dernier le
dernier grand crime contre l'humanité
reproché à barbie c'est la rafle duo la
raf c'est le dernier convoi du 11 août
1944 aux barbies choisi fait choisir 650
détenus 500 à montluc 150 aux prisons de
perrache à lyon à la fois juif et
résistants les met dans un convoi
un convoi ferroviaire tout à fait normal
un train de voyageurs est arrivé à auch
8 et a débarqué bien toute la population
juive tous les détenus juives qui
avaient été raflés par barbie ici dans
la prison de montluc
voilà le troisième fait donc on est en
présence d'actes qui sont bien sûr
typiquement des crimes contre l'humanité
on est bien d'accord
ces gens ont été choisis par barbie soit
parce qu'ils étaient juifs coupable
d'être nés juifs soit parce qu'il
faisait partie d'une communauté la
communauté des résistants qui avait osé
s'opposer à la doctrine nazie
donc on est bien en présence d'un crime
contre l'humanité et c'est dans ces
conditions que l'on a pu engager ce
procès principalement sur ses trois
affrontements
[Musique]
alors le procès n'a pas été totalement
diffusé en direct l'ouverture du procès
était diffusé en direct en mondiovision
je crois que c'est le seul cas où un
procès était diffusé à un procès
l'ouverture d'un procès a été diffusé en
mondovision l'organisation du procès
bien évidemment était de gérer la masse
du public qui souhaitaient assister au
procès que ce soient les victimes que ce
soit des journalistes 650 demande
d'accréditation de journalistes du monde
entier
il a fallu bien sûr organiser les débats
39 avocats de parties civiles plusieurs
dizaines et dizaines de victimes ce
procès a duré un mois et demi donc tous
à exiger bien sûr une organisation une
rationalisation des choses pour
qu'encore une fois ce procès se passe
dans la dignité et surtout dans le
strict respect des droits donné à la
défense
il fallait que barbie fut jugé avec tous
les droits que donne à un accusé un état
de droit un état démocratique
le procès barbie ce n'était pas la
vengeance de la victime non devenu
vainqueur le procès barbie c'est l acte
de justice poser dans sa plénitude qui
était la seule réponse qui était à la
hauteur de ce qu'avaient subis les
victimes de barbie
[Musique]
hélas hélas hélas barbie n'a jamais eu
le moindre la moindre expression de
regrets ou de compassion vis-à-vis des
victimes
barbie est offert mais et c'est ça le
drame dans la certitude qu'il n'a fait
que son devoir
il est s s il avait prêté le serment de
ss et à partir de là la fin justifiait
les moyens
le dernier mot qu'il a prononcés juste
avant que les jurés ne se retirent pour
délibérer
c'était de dire oui j'ai été sévère avec
la résistance
oui je n'ai pas j'ai été implacable mais
c'était la guerre et la guerre est finie
et pour barbie la guerre eh bien elle
permettait tout si barbie a émis un
regret c'est simplement qu hitler ait
perdu la guerre que son dieu ait perdu
la guerre
c'est ça le drame du fanatisme on n'a
pas de regard sur les victimes
on a deux regards que sur le service que
l'on rend à la croyance fanatiques qui
s'est emparée tout
[Musique]
la défense mise en place par les avocats
de barbie et est ce que l'on appelle la
défense de rupture c'était maître
jacques vergès qui en était le grand le
grand prêtre le grand propagandiste
ça consiste à mettre en cause la
légitimité de la juridiction a jugé la
personne qui comparaît devant elle on ne
va pas aborder la personnalité de celui
qu'on va juger on ne va pas aborder le
fond des faits qui sont reprochés à
l'accusé on va simplement dire vos juges
vous n'êtes pas légitime vous n'êtes pas
légitime a jugé barbie alors on a dit
vous n'êtes pas légitime parce que
barbie était tranquillement en bolivie
vous n'aviez pas à le à le récupérer de
la manière dont vous l'avez récupéré et
surtout vous français commençaient à
balayer devant votre porte qu'à regarder
ce qu'a fait la colonisation au 19e
siècle regardait le comportement qu'ont
eue les français il ya plusieurs
décennies
vous êtes mal placés pour reprocher à
barbie d'avoir été inhumé c'était un peu
ça c'était de l'évitement
alors que l'on aurait pu avoir une autre
mode de défense que l'on aurait pu
envisager un autre mode de défense
précisément en montrant comment un
garçon bien sous tous rapports devient
une véritable machine à tuer machine à
torture et parce que le fanatisme a fait
ses ravages
ça ça n'a pas du tout été évoquée barbie
trois jours après le début des débats à
n'a plus souhaité assister au procès
parce qu'il ne voulait pas avoir
il ne voulait pas avoir à donner des
explications il ne voulait pas se
retrouver devant les maires des enfants
d'izieu pour pouvoir tenter de justifier
l'injustifiable
alors il a commencé à dire qu'il n'y
était pour rien que vise yeux c'était
pas son s'était pas de son fait
malheureusement serge klarsfeld avait
retrouvé un télégramme par lequel 24
heures après les faits le même le soir
même des faits barbie rendez compte à sa
hiérarchie de la raf des enfants d'izieu
donc la signer klaus barbie c'était
difficile de difficile de dire que l'on
était étranger à ça donc barbie n'a pas
pu n'a pas pu ou n'a pas pu avoir un
seul moment de de regrets de remords
vis-à-vis de victimes
salah cela lui était je pense impossible
[Musique]
bien il faut essayer évidemment de ne
pas se laisser aller à l'émotion bien
que on serait des monstres cie en
entendant les horreurs que l'on a
entendu pendant près d'un mois et demi
on serait insensible
bien évidemment il faut se dire que même
l'individu qui a commis des crimes les
plus affreux adroit sa défense que l'on
doit se pencher sur son mode de défense
que l'on doit vérifier qu'il était
mentalement et qu'il demeure mentalement
entre guillemets normal c'est à dire
susceptibles d'être jugés
il faut essayer d'avoir ce minimum de
recul même si bien sûr bien sûr le juge
encore une fois n'est pas insensible au
drame que l'on vient rappeler rappelé
devant lui c'est bien sûr la grande
difficulté mais cette difficulté elles
existent également tout au long de la
vie d'un juge qui va avoir devant lui
des crimes affreux d d d d d d d des
victimes des parents des enfants de gens
qui ont été tuées assassinées deux des
jeunes filles violées des gens qui ont
été atteints dans leur chair et il faut
qu'ils gardent bien évidemment ce recul
qui n'est pas encore une fois
antinomique à une certaine empathie pour
pouvoir tenter de poser d'une manière
tout à fait ne tout à fait équitable
l'acte de justice que l'on attend de lui
nous nous étions l'accusation le juge
n'est jamais seul et c'est une très
grande garante et que celle de la
collégialité
barbie a été jugé par douze personnes
trois magistrats professionnels et neuf
jurés et pour condamner barbie il a
fallait une majorité d'au moins huit
mois sur douze
donc cette par une majorité d'au moins
huit voix surdose que barbie a été
condamné
[Musique]
c'est très difficile de dire qu'il ya eu
un témoignage qui a plus marqué qu'un
autre je pense que le témoignage de ces
femmes qui ont été déportée à
ravensbrück qui sont venus expliquer ce
qu'elle avait subis c'était quelque
chose de poignant et puis surtout bien
sûr les mères des enfants d'izieu
la directrice de cette colonie d'
enfants d'izieu qui par bonheur pour
elle n'était pas là ce jour là et qui
est venu et exhale et le drame de ses
enfants
bien évidemment c'était des moments les
plus les plus dramatiques mais je dirais
chaque témoin même ceux qui ont été
moins spectaculaire qu'on était plus
réservé à porter à un lot de souffrances
lot de non dits qui était émouvant donc
c'est très difficile de d'établir un
palmarès
si l'on peut dire si l'on peut dire
les leçons du procès barbie c'est
évidemment porter le témoignage de ce
qui s'est dit l'intérêt du procès barbie
encore une fois c'est qu'il a été filmé
ce qui fait aujourd'hui en présentant à
la jeune génération
le témoignage du vécu absolument
inimaginable de certaines personnes qui
peuvent être proche d'eux eh bien ça ça
permet de tenir le langage des lots sont
l'histoire s'il n'y avait pas de leçons
à tirer du procès barbie le procès
barbie n'aurait servi à rien et
aujourd'hui montrer ce que peut faire le
fanatisme par les temps où des jeunes
sont tentés d'aller par verre par
adhésion à je ne sais quelle philosophie
folle de des chalets se faire exploser
au milieu de populations montrer ce que
peut fabriquer le fanatisme
ça c'est véritablement la mission que
l'on doit avoir en tirant les leçons du
procès barbie le procès barbie c'est le
procès de la démonstration de ce que
peut faire le fanatisme ici à nos portes
le peuple allemand était un des peuples
les plus brillants les plus intelligents
que l'on connaisse au 18ème 19ème siècle
voilà comment un dictateur est parvenu à
capter la conscience on peut employer ce
mot d'individus éminemment intelligent
pour les transformer en bar bar le
procès barbie c'était véritablement un
moment où la nation française a fait une
démarche de mémoire collective qu'elle
n'avait encore jamais fait jusqu'à ce
moment-là en direction de l'universalité
des victimes du nazisme
que ce soit les résistants que ce soit
les juifs que ce soit les simples aux
rafles et on a nationalement d'une
manière tout à fait transcendant toutes
les différences toutes les sensibilités
et bien entrepris cette démarche de
regarder dans le rétroviseur de
l'histoire non pas par volonté de
de passéiste ou de je ne sais quoi mais
précisément pour retirer les leçons dont
l'actualité des leçons du procès barbie
[Musique]
e